foreign
hey Michael welcome to the show
hello uh I'm a college professor and I'm
single with no kids so I live on campus
in a private dorm room and that saves me
about eleven hundred dollars a month
nice so my co-worker my co-workers oh I
like where this is going all right my
co-worker who's a big Dave Ramsey fan he
says that I should move out because no
girl is ever going to want to date a guy
who lives
and has that been true for you so far
um I think my issue in that area is less
about my living situation and more about
I'm just kind of in a smaller town
and uh yeah there's a couple of
collectivity issues going on there but
I've never met anybody that said like
well I don't want to go out with you
because you know I don't think so
Michael at least not the kind of woman
you would want eventually like to marry
right I mean if you're living with your
parents I could see someone being like
hmm okay so what are we doing there uh
but you're a professor at the school and
so your room and board is as if it's
free right for you you're not paying
anything well no it's it's just really
really cheap okay okay everything
no bills or anything yeah didn't alone
live on campus yeah he did with his van
with with Sheila and I want to say one
more a baby a baby we're getting a baby
signal from the booth yeah still yeah Dr
John zalonia that's uh that's a host on
the show he him and his wife that's
right Sheila they they lived there and
he's like the coolest of the
personalities so like if you need
somebody with some swag you can be like
hey deloney did it alone he lived in a
dorm with with a wife and a kid no
Michael I don't I don't think so at all
I don't think that that's going to be a
major turn I don't think it would be for
me I think again it's and it's not
because you don't you you lack uh drive
or willpower like those kind of things
could be a label on someone that's still
living at home that you're like um why
are you still living at home uh but
you're doing it for a reason
intentionally and it's a yeah I don't
that doesn't so so did this friend who
said you're not going to be able to have
any game if you live in a dorm is he
broke
um well he's married he's he's all right
he's doing all right
I feel like there's a good chance that
you might be taking advice from somebody
who's broke because he's a big Dave
Ramsey fan though right is he a Ramsey
Show fan the friends you said yeah I
mean he he doesn't have a bunch of
income but he's doing well for him so
he's doing all right for himself uh yeah
he's not broke bro so listen Michael
here's here's what I here's my I wish
the lonely was on the show to give you
relational advice here's my thing if it
becomes a pattern of women that you
really do a woman that you really like
and you guys have been dating and she's
like I can't date you anymore because
you live in the dorm and that happens
two three times then maybe there's a
pattern of okay maybe Christine and
Rachel were wrong maybe maybe that this
thing is is an issue but I just don't
think that's gonna happen and also also
like if you are on this plan and you
want to build wealth and your goal is to
be a baby steps millionaire I mean do
you really want to be with someone who
has a problem with you scrimping and
saving and doing what it's what you've
got to do to build wealth
here's a question for you Michael are do
you eventually want to be a homeowner
there like is that in your future to say
I would love to own a home because
owning a home is a great investment and
we do recommend people doing that when
the time is right for them financially
so is that that's a goal for you right
you don't want to live in a dorm your
whole life
but honestly I say now you might be
turning against me because here's my
position if I get married yes but if I
just end up not being married then I'm
not buy a house
if it's just me just single me I don't
even have any pets or anything I
wouldn't buy a house okay well
I would disagree a little bit I think
owning a home and having equity and all
that I think is just a great asset to
your overall Financial picture uh but I
but for the day for the moment you're in
and for the dating advice that Christina
and I are going to give you I think
you're good I think you're fine uh yeah
well thanks for the call that is that is
a great question I hope I'm I hope I'm
right sorry Michael if I ruined your
love life like if if I am wrong and
people won't date you because you're in
a dorm but I don't think that's gonna be
the case